hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to imposter hide
an among us horror game now i know among
us might be a horror game to some of you
but this one is a 3d free roam ish
i'm not 100 sure but a game where you
have to hide from imposters and
apparently they're
quite deadly but why don't we give it a
try level one here we go
okay inspect sample electrical man the
field of view on this son of a
what oh it's me
this is one of the boy
what is that that's new um that's weird
and new
and uh why
oh oh oh that's why oh that's why
hey bud oh god okay um
okay okay okay
okay hide
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
is your ash bleeding oh no wait no hang
on
oh wait isn't the reactor is that on the
other side i don't remember where that
is
oh no whoa
sorry also god damn it i'm sorry if the
audio is a little
strange my go xlr mysteriously got
soylent spilled all over it completely
not my fault i don't know what's
happening
uh no not power definitely not power
it's probably a reactor thing i don't
know
oh boy oh boy
wait wait that's it just have to open
that doesn't seem to be my thing um
well it's probably to do with the thing
that was on the other side
but then again i don't exactly know
what's happening so i'm kind of screwed
oh oh god no
hey how's it going friend
oh okay i'm just gonna run around
[Music]
good god and they sure do a good job of
making this intense
but also hang on
whoa i did it
i don't know map is there a map
oh oh uh oh
okay
it's like a star over here
okay there we go jesus okay
thanks buddy now i know exactly what i'm
supposed to do at all times
god i don't know why my audio is just
redlining like that
it's freaking loud dude and also my
keyboard got super broken
bam i'm the best
especially at moons you know there's a
lot of crew here and there are a lot of
kinds of dead
i don't know if that's my problem i'm
gonna guess
no okay you i
did it whatever i did i did it
all right oh no that ain't good
oh fix lights oh no
i can see my own jiggly ass from my side
view
oh can they use the vents can they use
the vents
i don't like the power being out oh
please
oh please okay
we're good to go i think anyway there's
a lot freakier than i thought it'd be
hope it doesn't never turn into like a
2v1 or something like that
all right hello i would like to boink
boink
okay did it i would like to boing us
troingus
i did it i did it
i didn't i did it
he's not very fast but i'd hate to lose
this right when i'm about to win it
gotta hope the audio is okay i've never
seen a redline the way it is
that's probably fun oh god hey
bud how you doing good to see you
okay yeah all right a flavoring oh how
did you do that from where you are
why do i keep slamming into the right
also this keyboard that i have as a
backup sucks
ass god i keep accidentally pressing
buttons
okay please please please please please
please please please please please
please please please please
thank goodness you're not nearly as fast
as i am
these custom games sure are nice to me
what
is that by the way by the by
what in the world is that floating
outside i think we got a lot of more
questions about the universe of among us
than i previously imagined that we would
like flying amoeba monsters
and that's being nice that's being real
nice i've been ignoring all the
invaginations all over your body
i can call you much meaner things hey
i'm not gonna though i'm not gonna look
this douche is kind of persistent
and he seems to be kind of stuck seems
to be kind of smart about some things
ye ah oh am i cornered oh am i cornered
oh am i cornered oh am i cornered
oh am i cornered what am i doing oh no
i'll hide there was a hide ah
he'll never check the vents i'm
perfectly safe
i have to fix the goddamn lights is that
what happened in the middle of that test
i
can i get a sodi pop i would definitely
not mind a sodi pop
i would also definitely not mind being
able to do my goddamn job
all right let me exp inspect the goddamn
sample before i
have to i don't know go somewhere where
are we going anyway
that's what i've always wanted to know
and that's what i've always asked in
among us lobbies but no one seems to
ever want to talk about it
no one seems to want to question the
reality of our situation you know what i
mean
oh i did it i'm the best
but no one ever wants to question the
reality of the situation heck maybe
that's just my
yearning for role play and maybe i just
want stand the water man back but in
among us
maybe i'm just looking for human
connection
now whatever i'm going to the next level
okay thank you what do i do what do i do
oh
right good that's great
i don't hear anybody which i'm assuming
is okay
i'm really nailing all my tasks
come on no no get down there we go
so far so good
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
good thing they announced themselves by
screaming i mean so do i but
like it's only fair that i
play fair okay almost there almost there
almost there
diverting power that was easy i'm gonna
freaking nail this
oh god damn you
where are you where are you are you are
you over here you overhear you over here
no you're not hey yeah you went the
wrong way
why is it is there a ghost on the ship i
mean i know that technically when people
die there are ghosts floating all around
and these ghosts of these bodies are
definitely judging me for my actions and
my inability to successfully do what i
need to do
but oh god one two three four five
seven eight nine bam
what do i get the points for i mean
obviously there should be a lot more
fanfare once i'm done with this like uh
definitely some balloons and some
confetti going on here
but what are the what are the what
inventory oh
oh hats i don't care i don't care
all right well is it gonna get tough
that's what i gotta ask about this is
ever gonna get hard can i bring an
emergency meeting
oh my god oh my goodness god
ow ah wait why did i go in here oh
my god oh my god this is terrible why am
i doing this now
why am i doing this now oh my god oh my
god i'm an idiot
you'll never find me
he's stupid and i'm smart you an idiot
and i'm so
big brained yeah
well i don't like the sound of that but
uh thankfully i don't have to deal with
it
because i'm smart and they're dumb
okay what is it what am i doing here
uploading uploading
why do i have to stand here when it's
imploding shouldn't i be able to
literally go anywhere else while it's
imploding
i'd really appreciate it okay what am i
doing here
oh more wires god damn it oh
yeah oh yeah
okay that's good that's good that's good
this is all very good
ah oh
i see i see i see
okay that's one now that i know i need
to get two of these
i hear something gurgling all right
whatever the gurgles can be there
i don't need to worry about that all i
need to worry about is getting these
things fixed
and then i'm on my way okay all done
yay there he is that's good
hey good to see you buddy how are you
oh god okay in here
[Music]
i mean you know i gotta give it to him
this is a pretty faithful recreation of
a plot
frickin what the frick are you talking
about no one should be able to moan at
those volumes
played a lot of games bro there's a lot
of moaning going on
not like that but you know i played a
lot of games where there's a lot of
owning going on
maybe like that but this guy's moaning
ability really is
stellar oh and boom i win
i'm the best i'm incredible these guys
kind of suck
you know i'm not going to lie these guys
kind of suck the difficulty isn't
exactly going up
the way it should be got to keep playing
it's good it's kind of fun
solo among us solomongas
when do they start going in vents when
do they start appearing out of nowhere
oh swipe card
got it is this where they get all big
brained and they start popping out of
random places
i'd like to think that it gets smarter
more devious
oh okay i'm gonna fix the lights now
please
all right i'm gonna go around god i hate
games where the run is just only
slightly faster than the whoa
hey pal well you're kind of where i need
to be don't you
ain't you ain't you isn't you you know
this game kind of hides between its
cartoonish exterior but it actually is
quite a horrible violent game what are
you doing over there
oh my god wait is there two of them oh
wait
wait a minute oh wait how do i how do i
how do i how do i how do i
uh what do i do
hey oh i'm gonna win i'm gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay now we're getting a little more
difficult here now we're getting
somewhere
now i'm starting to feel something
instead of the numbness that permeates
my soul
now i'm starting to feel a thrill
yeah i don't want to feel the thrill
that early and wait no no the thrill can
wait
for the thrill can wait okay
don't come in here he's gonna come in
here he's coming in here basically
[Music]
that's bad that's a bad thing that's a
bad sign
oh okay we're fine so far so good
okay good i'm going the wrong way now i
decided to go not the correct way and i
went around
that's good oh whoa
i'm one of you all right all right all
right
okay lights lie lights
lights in here lights
oh you dick you really gotta start all
the way over if you goof it
oh
i did it i'm a genius
that sounds bad but i'm gonna assume
it's okay
it was wasn't really a line but who
really cares not me definitely not me
okay i win i'm the greatest
all right here we go come on present me
with a challenge i'm going the wrong way
present me with a challenge present me
present
thyself i think the moaning is coming
from the creature outside the ship
you know the big tentacle creature that
looks like an amoeba and other things
but that doesn't really make sense
because kind of breaks the laws of
physics
considering that would mean that it's
able to
send sound across time and space a
medium that does not transfer any sound
waves
which kind of ain't a thing kind of
weird that i haven't seen any of them
kind of odd kind of kind of a little
bizarre
i'm kind of questioning the reality of
my situation
there's more moaning okay well good
i was hoping for that kind of weird
kind of strange don't know where they
are
kind of bizarre
this is stressful come on hurry up
hurry hurry hurry
hurry
okay now the sample and i'm out of here
home free okay there you are hey
i was wondering i was wondering you know
i was wondering where he was it does
however seem like it's only the one
which is cool i guess
oh hey
okay we're good we're good we're good
we're good we're good okay this is going
great
all right good man um is this going to
get hard anytime soon or am i just going
to cruise my way through this
because i am such a badass
nice
what was that sound what was that that
was a new one
what is over here what oh what are you
what are you
oh no the other way around i don't even
remember that one
oh no but you're in the way aren't you
oh no you're in the way aren't you can i
go around oh can i go run please i'll be
around this way
oh that'd be bad okay where'd you go
oh where did you go oh i don't like that
oh i don't like that okay
we're fine stop
moaning you're gonna give away my
position
there's a little bit more i don't know
why i keep trying to
go deeper on this oh i hear
i hear things okay blah
blah you know what i'm actually going to
buy a hat i'm enjoying this
i'm enjoying this oh plunger that's nice
i like that that's good i'll buy that oh
there i go
and then uh color uh
piss yellow so i'm walking toilet that's
what i'd like to think
all right here we go and away here we go
eventually i'm going to have to take
advantage of the hiding mechanics i know
that
but not before i try every single type
of thing that i can do
where am i going where am i going bang
bang boom
boom any day now okay good
god i'm just gonna keep going until i
die
i wanna see how good i get at this and
whether or not they actually get
smarter there i go
hello hi who was that
hi okay it's fine you know if
if the monsters had to actually the
imposters actually had to announce
themselves the way that you guys do
the reel among us would not be that
difficult at all
right lightning speed
not very lighting speed okay
you keep saying it's getting harder but
i'm not feeling the hardness
i want to feel it hard ah give me a
challenge
i'm only getting better at this game you
guys are getting worse
you guys are sucking it up you guys
gotta get good
no don't like the sound of that whoa at
what point are they just gonna turn into
regular people
and actually try to be stealthy about it
and lights are gonna go out or something
by the time i get this
okay that's gonna come back yep i knew
it how did i know it maybe i'm a genius
maybe i'm some kind of big smart maybe
i'm some kind of among us
pro where are the among us leagues
well that sounds bad is bad it is bad
well funnily enough when i go around the
corner it is bad
you know before you know you could still
do the things that you needed to do
without having to go back and fix the
lights couldn't you wasn't that a thing
was that like a thing
hey okay you're really cutting me off
here and i don't like it i don't push
much what if i hide there's no way you
would
oh hi
i really don't like those sounds i'm
gonna go for it i'm gonna go for it i'm
gonna go for it
oh i need to get these lights back on
because this place is not fun at night
i mean it's in space so it's always
night i guess
okay i'm gonna go inspect my sample
oh no don't corner me
[Music]
oh no oh
all right i'll go the long way around
you freaking
freaking goose bags yeah you better stop
thumping lumping just let me do what i
came here to do which is what i don't
know
why are we in space where is we going
what is we doing what is any of this
why is any of this who are we what are
we even doing
okay level 10 the final level
if ever there was a way for them to get
really good and kill me
now might be the chance for them to do
exactly that
and i'm gonna do if there's a goddamn
inspect thing i'm gonna do it first
part of back and forthing around this
thing scan me
i'm not really in there someone's going
to be suspicious of me
okay now it'd be a global sorry
the hurry is what you would do now
oh hey what's up hey
how are you doing this is going to take
a while
oh god oh god oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh
no that was a door behind me oh no
oh no now hey hey
hi hi how are you hey what's up hey how
you doing okay good to see you okay
bye oh
oh oh oh
oh okay okay okay okay
there was something in there that i
needed to do okay that's fine that's
fine that's fine
no hurry oh my god oh my god click it
oh my god oh my god oh my god i'm gonna
die i'm dead
i'm a dead man who walks around whoo i'm
fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i really
blew out the microphone there i could
hear it
oh i'm trying not to i'm really trying
not to
go damn it i'm a dead man
oh i'm a dead man oh i'm dead oh
i'm not dead i'm not dead i am a winner
[Laughter]
turns out i win
i'm the best all right you guys better
actually get good because this is
pathetic of you
that's not good
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
you better not box me in here oh no oh
that's not good um um
thankfully that doesn't seem to blow up
the ship like it has in the past
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh okay good good good good good good i
gotta go to the reactor all the way back
there
okay we're good we're clear we're clear
last thing last thing last thing last
thing we're good we're good we're good
okay done i'm the best
try me difficulty 200. you guys better
be good
this is getting purely pathetic god how
many upload
datas do i have oh
come on
all the plotting all of the bloating
oh my god the floating oh the bloating
come on come on come on come on
come on
oh shoot oh shooty tooty okay shooty
oh all right if they could just not be
go
ma oh oh wait wait oh no
um bring around the rosie okay ring
around my rosie
you gonna ring around my rosie hello
i don't know they're an idiot i'm smart
they're just dumb and bad
bam lucky number 13.
[Music]
did i do it okay
hey what's up buddy hey how you doing
hey what's up what's up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah maybe i'm being
a little bolder but i think i can get
this before you get me
i'm out of here oh no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
none of that none of that thank you very
much none of that
of course oh my god good thing i'm in
the room where i need to do that thing
good thing i'm here okay good
and all the other stuff is over over
there anyway so this is all good
okay clear okay i just need to chart a
course and then i need to clear the
asteroids and then i'm good to go
okay is there anything else here that
i'm missing i've never actually taken a
moment to look at anything around here
no oh that's something i'm not supposed
to see
what are you what are you
oh my god it's mouth or is that it's
butthole how would you ever know
don't don't don't you even think about
it
don't even think about it oh it was
look at you oh oh oh okay hi
hi oh no
ah
[Music]
shoot the thing oh my god oh my god what
is that about
i can't save oh you oh fix the
goddamn lights oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god
you are a douche freaking block in my
view like that
okay now for realsies
now for realsies now for realsies
let's do this without someone's fat ass
in the way of my gun
oh okay well this is gonna be dicey
oh this is gonna be down to the wire
well this is probably a gamble i
shouldn't take
okay kaboom
come on damn it kaboom kaboom
uh i'm the best i'm the best
i'm goddamn great i am unstoppable
unflappable
i can't be flapped no one's ever flapped
me before
they're probably a lot of other details
in this game that i'm just not aware of
i haven't been paying attention or
something i'm gonna actually save this
one
because it's near the electric actually
no i'll just keep the one in electrical
to do the electrical one
you you never noticed a thing
was that three i think that might have
been three i think that might have been
three i see your game
good thing i know an alternate path
through all this
[Music]
oh oh it is three it's three
okay let me get one thing straight you
guys not very threatening
not very fast not very smart
i'm curious i'm really curious
[Music]
if i just go around the corner they lose
me
oh god oh no wait wait a minute
wait a minute where are you oh hey
okay how close you oh god
ow all right okay i've been playing this
for like 40 minutes
it's actually quite fun i don't know if
it's completely like endless
but it is very interesting you know i
gotta give it that it's a faithful
recreation like i think it was quite fun
not too shabby so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you want to play
this who is free over on ichio
uh link is in the description hey did
you know that me bob and wade have a
podcast
if you want to go listen to it that link
is also in the description it's called
distractable i've talked about it a lot
and i'm going to keep talking about it
because very fun
and very funny and if you want to get a
good laugh there's a link to the bob's
fridge episode
where bob uh bob talks about his fridge
delivery that didn't go so well so link
is in the description or you can look it
up on any podcast thing
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you